oh hello there
this episode of biographics is brought
to finish my mouth
[Music]
this episode of biographies is brought
to you by magic spoon if you're a
regular viewer of my channel you know
that i love cereal unfortunately doesn't
always love you bad given the most
cereals are over processed
and absolutely slammed with sugar there
were several years where i just never
ate any cereal because it just
has more sugar than i need in my life
well along comes a magic spoon you're
like look
fact boy we've got a cereal that has no
sugar lots of protein and just three
grams of net carbs per
serving and it's only 110 calories cool
i think i don't know much about protein
and carbs other than the former is good
and the latter probably not so much but
that
zero sugar thing had me sold and it
turns out you'd be like oh that's not
gonna taste very good is it and it
actually tastes
amazing it's like it's loaded with sugar
except that it's not
now originally they had four flavors
cocoa fruity frosted and blueberry but
just recently much to my delight they've
added some new ones including peanut
butter and cinnamon
right now for a limited time magic spoon
is bringing back their small batch
birthday cake flavor which you can buy
in a special 5-pack in honor of their
birthday
everyone really loved it last year so
it's sure to be popular again
this year i haven't actually got my
package of it yet
but i know it'll be good because it's
from magic spoon use my promo code
biographics you're at five
dollars off magic spoon is a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it they'll give you a money back perfect
and let's get into today's video
[Music]
the east end of london is not a place
that has always benefited from a
positive reputation quite the opposite
in fact
for centuries it was regarded as one of
the city's poorest and most crime-ridden
areas this image was reinforced by
writers such as george gissing who
referred to it as the
city of the dead and american author
jack london who actually lived there for
a few weeks and gave a first-hand
account of the hellish conditions he
witnessed in
the people of the abyss the area was
filled with working-class people many of
them immigrants who were jammed into
overcrowded and dilapidated buildings
and
often resorted to vices such as drinking
and prostitution to forget about the
pain of their squalid existence wherever
there weren't tenement buildings there
were glue factories rendering plants
tanning yards coal works soap boilers
and slaughter houses
all the dirty and foul trades were
confined to the east denser as not to
tarnish the
richer more fashionable west end of
london consequently the east end was
also rife with crime
the radcliffe highway is located there a
road historically infamous for many
seedy businesses but also where the
notorious ratcliffe murders took place
whitechapel is also in the east end the
area once prowled by jack the ripper
during the mid-20th century the area
became more and more associated with
organized crime and
two brothers soon emerged as the
undisputed kings of the east end they
were the cray twins and alongside their
gang which they dubbed the firm
they were responsible for most criminal
rackets in the area during the 1950s but
this was just the beginning for ronnie
and reggie as they used their influence
and money to
open nightclubs in the west end these
were popular and fashionable and all of
a sudden the cray twins were celebrities
in their own right mingling with stars
and socialites from
both london and across the pond the
craze became an integral part of the pop
culture of the swinging 60s in the uk
just as much as miniskirts mods and
music
ronald and reginald cray were born on
october 24 1933 in hoxton east london to
charles senior and vile at annie cray
they were twins although reggie was 10
minutes older than ronnie they also had
another brother charles james who was
six years older than both of them
their father was a traveling trader who
roamed the country buying and selling
various items particularly clothing and
jewelry his presence in the twin's life
was
sporadic not only due to his job but
also because he had to go on the run in
after refusing to be conscripted into
world war ii
the boy's upbringing was mainly handled
by the many women in their lives their
mother their aunts and their
grandmothers ronnie and reggie left
school when they were both 15 years old
looking for employment they worked
various odd jobs including six months in
the
billingsgate fish market which would end
up becoming the longest legitimate job
that they would ever have
the twins also started developing a
reputation as neighborhood tough guys
always
getting into fights and other scrapes
their maternal grandfather jimmy
cannonball lee used to be a boxer in his
day so
he turned them onto the sport both
siblings were quite proficient although
reggie was the standout in 1948 he
became the london schoolboy champion and
made it to the finals of the great
britain schoolboy event her other
brother charlie recalled that boxing was
one of the first things to showcase the
different personalities of the twins
reggie was cool and calculated he showed
skill and
willingness to learn from advice ronnie
on the other hand was a bit more of a
raging bull who charged headfirst and
usually won by overpowering his opponent
one personality trait they did share
however was that neither brother
responded well to authority as was
exemptified in 1952 when they were
called up for national service in the
british army back then all young healthy
males between 17 and 21 years of age
were required to serve two years in the
armed forces in the case of ronnie and
reggie they were assigned to an infantry
regiment called the royal fusiliers at
the tower of london but
immediately got into trouble when they
arrived there they got into an argument
with one of the training sergeants they
beat him up and left the barracks to go
back home the twins were arrested the
following day and sent to military
prison in fact most of their time
doing national service was spent either
in a military prison or going on the run
they often got into fights left their
barracks without permission and
unsurprisingly they both got
court-martialed and received
dishonorable discharges after which they
were transferred to a civilian prison to
serve some time for several offenses
that they committed off-base
[Music]
the court marshals pretty much sunk both
of their boxing careers so after they
got out the craze needed to find
something new to do they started out
small they got a loan from their older
brother and leased a pool hall in
bethnal green
during their time spent in jail ronnie
and reggie had already befriended plenty
of other shady characters and the pool
hall soon turned into a regular
haunt for many of their army buddies and
other local hoodlums the twins and their
entourage would often gather at the club
then
go out at night to the pubs where two
things were always guaranteed to happen
drinking and rolling as a means of
making money the twins took advantage of
the fact that their billiard hall wasn't
yet on the police's radar so they
allowed a few local fences to store
their stolen goods there and
even conduct business with a cut of the
profits going to the crate of course
inevitably
this got them unwanted attention from
some of the other neighborhood gangsters
who did not appreciate the twins doing
business on their turf specifically the
craze received a message from three
brothers all dock workers who invited
the twins to stop by their pub on a
sunday morning
for a drink and a talk of course ronnie
and reggie understood that this was a
trap but they went anyway as soon as
they entered the door was locked and
the pub landlord made himself scarce as
the three dockers lunged at the twins to
teach them a lesson but it didn't go as
they planned when the landlord returned
he found two of the dock workers
unconscious while the third one was
still being pummeled senseless by ronnie
cray
although young the craze made it pretty
evident that they were legitimate tough
guys who
could not be intimidated and their gang
grew pretty quickly by the time they
turned 21 years old the craze had their
fingers in a lot of pies including
extortion theft gambling robbery and
cons this was all still
local though and the craze were ready to
move up in the world
in 1956 they became embroiled in a gang
war as the two top kingpins of the east
end billy hill
and jack spot coma fought for power coma
used the craze for
muscle but ultimately they were on the
losing side
one night coma and his wife were
attacked by hill's enforcer mad frankie
frasier and his men he had his face
slashed very badly and eventually coma
decided to call it quits while he was
still alive
despite coming up on top billy hill
didn't remain involved in the underworld
of london's east end for long the
departures of him and coma created a
power void and several new gangs rose up
to fill it unsurprisingly one of them
belonged to the craze who
called their burgeoning crime outfit the
firm ronnie and reggie were of course at
the head of the table their older
brother charlie cray was also a member
although he later claims not to have
been involved in the violent stuff and
mainly to have acted as the legitimate
front man for many of their operations
a cousin named ronnie hart was also part
of the firm as were dozens of other men
we're not going to name them all but
just a few other key members were john
dixon
albert donahue ian barry and connie
whitehead in just a few years the firm
emerged as one of london's most
dangerous gangs as the craze controlled
a large area of the east end where every
business be it legitimate or illegal
paid its dues to the twins of course
with this ascendancy within london's
criminal underworld
also came more attention from the police
the craze first got into hot water in
late 1956 when
ronnie shot someone for the first time
the target was a man who threatened to
beat up a car dealer under the
protection of the firm only got into a
flight with him and during the struggle
shot the guy once in the leg
the man later went to the police but the
craze got off using a bit of twin
trickery the authorities picked up one
of the craze they
formally charged him and the victim id'd
him only after this was done did the
accused reveal himself to be reggie
crane not ronnie and presented an
airtight alibi for the time of the
shooting
embarrassed that police had no choice
but to release him and the whole matter
was dropped after the victim received
some unofficial compensation from the
firm for his suffering now not all
altercations went this smoothly
later that same year the craze became
partners in a west end club called the
stragglers located in soho it was the
first of many such
ventures but in this particular case the
role of the craze was to keep out the
troublemakers
looking to start fights so the club
could begin attracting a higher class of
clientele
unsurprisingly this led to conflict
bobby ramsey the guy who brought in the
craze on the deal
got on the wrong side of a gang called
the watmey streeters who ambushed him
one night and gave him a serious beating
the craze had no choice but to respond
to this attack so a few weeks later the
firm raided a pub called the britannia
which was a hangout of the watneys
however the latter got wind of the
attack so everybody managed to escape
out of the back door except for a guy
called terry martin who was stabbed and
beaten with an inch of his life
later that night as cars with firm
members prowled the east end looking for
more watneys one of them was
stopped by a police patrol it contained
ramsay and ronnie cray who were
both arrested for the assault of terry
martin reggie was also brought in but he
was later released ronnie on the other
hand got three years in jail
in november 1956 he went to warnsworth
prison leaving reggie cray as the sole
boss of the firm
at first rodney took to prison life
reasonably well thanks to his
connections and entourage that provided
him with all the comforts that one could
find on the inside however things got
worse after he was transferred away from
london he was showing signs of paranoia
which only got worse after he heard that
his aunt rose had passed away
nowadays he would have been deemed a
paranoid schizophrenic with homicidal
tendencies but in the 1950s he was
simply diagnosed with prison psychosis
and certified insane on the outside
reggie crate was doing significantly
better
although he was a very violent man he
was more cool and collected than his
brother was and he was more interested
in becoming a successful businessman
than a tough gangster reggie also
thought it was time to move out of the
old pool hall into new headquarters so
he opened the double r club on bell road
it became quite a trendy london hangout
and gave the craze their first taste of
mingling with the stars charlie cray who
was brought in to handle the day-to-day
running of the club even had a six-month
fling with an actress and
future dame barbara windsor most famous
for her roles in the carry-on films
in 1959 ronnie cray was released from
prison the following year the betting
and gaming act of 1960 was passed which
legalized additional forms of gambling
in the uk the craze were among the first
to take advantage of this new law when
they opened a gambling cub called
esmerelda's barn it became
a giant gold mine for the twins but
trouble struck again as this time reggie
was given an 18-month prison sentence
for attempted extortion
[Music]
finally in 1961 both crays were out and
free of legal troubles the firm was
established as one of london's biggest
and baddest criminal outfits collecting
tributes each month from a long list of
businesses that
extended beyond the east end furthermore
the crazed developing reputation of
successful club owners meant
that they kept receiving new offers from
other clubs wanting to take them on as
partners
business was booming the crays were
making a lot of money while
living out their fantasy lifestyles and
rubbing elbows with the rich and
powerful
strangely enough when the twins did find
themselves embroiled in scandal it had
nothing to do with their criminal empire
but rather for their sexual exploits for
most of his life ronnie cray was openly
gay and
had a lot of relationships with young
men who worked in his nightclubs and
gambling halls later on he married two
women while incarcerated
elaine mildener and kate howard but he
divorced them both after a few years
reggie preferred to keep it more private
he was also married twice and to the
world at large he maintained that he was
straight although rumors that he was
bisexual had always persisted it was
mainly after reggie's death
some other people close to him mentioned
that he had had several relationships
with men
the reason this became relevant was
because in 1964 a british tabloid ran a
story about a prominent politician a
member of the house of lords
who was having an affair with a
notorious gangster they even had a
photograph of the two together but due
to british libel laws they could not
publish it or even
mention the name of the politician the
foreign press however had no such
concern for these laws so a german
publication named the bose
ronnie cray and lord boothby obviously
the member of parliament denied this
allegation claiming that he only met
ronnie cray for a business meeting
he sued the tabloid and won a large
settlement plus a public apology which
discouraged other newspapers from
covering the story however decades later
declassified files showed that the home
office took the matter very seriously
and had boothby secretly investigated by
mi5
the report described lord boothby as a
kinky fellow
but mentioned that the tabloids got the
story wrong he and ronnie cray were not
having an affair but they did attend a
few gay parties together as they both
preferred younger men
ultimately ni5 concluded that the matter
was of no national concern so the
boothby affair was
largely forgotten once again the craze
were back to business as usual but it
would not be until long after
that business was disrupted permanently
the firm seemed pretty protected from
the law but the same could not be said
when it came to other gangs there were
still plenty of dangerous criminals in
london's underworld who had
no love for the crate twins and chief
among them was the richardson gang they
were
rivals of the firm throughout the 1960s
and often butted heads over
the same racquets they were quite
vicious with a reputation for torture
and included members such as the leaders
charles and eddie richardson
the aforementioned mad frankie frasier
and a giant bull of a man with a mean
streak
named george cornell a former member of
the watney street gang the conflict
between the two groups reached its peak
on march the 8th 1966 when a large-scale
fight between the two sides erupted
at a club named mr smith the three men
were seriously injured during a brawl
and an associate of the craze named
dickie hart was
shot and killed roddy and reggie were
not present during the fight
and neither was cornell on the side of
the richardson's two days later however
george canal went to the hospital to
visit one of the gang members who got
injured in the fight
after he left he stopped for a drink at
a pub in white chapel called the blind
beggar
unbeknownst to him the craze and a few
other members of the firm were drinking
in another pub just a few hundred yards
away
somebody called to inform them of
cornell's whereabouts at which point
ronnie craig got into a car with john
dixon
and zee and barry and drove to the blind
beggar as soon as they entered the pub
george cornell turned around and said
something along the lines of well just
look who's here
those were his last words as ronnie
craig walked up to him pulled out a nine
millimeter pistol
and shot him in the head berry shot a
few times in the ceiling for
intimidation and
the couple calmly walked out of the
blind beggar and drove away despite the
obvious nature of the crime ronnie was
safe from the law for the time being
the police were finding it hard to build
a case against him as nobody wanted to
testify
either that or they were waiting for the
right moment when they would be able to
send
both twins to prison at once they didn't
have to wait too long although reggie
was usually the more level-headed
sibling in 1967 he too fell into a deep
depression with violent mood swings
after his wife francis shear died of an
apparent suicide this led him to
committing his first and as far as we
know
only murder something which he did at
the insistence of his brother who up
until that point had been
annoyed by the fact that reggie never
took that fatal final step the target
was a criminal named jack
the hat macvittie he wasn't a member of
the firm but he was an associate used
for the occasional job at the time he
was on bad terms with the twins chiefly
for
bungling a hit he was supposed to carry
out and then refusing to pay back the
advance he was given
on the night of october 28 1967 most of
the firm was drinking at a pub called
the carpenter's arms when
word came in that mcvitty was on his way
the craze cleared the place of other
guests and got into an argument with him
as soon as he walked through the door
reggie pulled out a gun and squeezed the
trigger but it jammed he then pounced on
mcvitty and with his brother screaming
next to him he
began to stab him in the face neck and
chest once the deed was done
some of the other firm members disposed
of the body which has never been
recovered
[Music]
the death of jackie macvittie proved to
be the beginning of the end for the
crate wins for starters it caused a lot
of tension within the firm as members
felt like what had happened to macvittie
could also happen to them furthermore
unbeknownst to the craze scotland yard
had been collecting evidence and
testimonies against them since 1964
under the command of leonard nipper reed
in may 1968 the police decided that it
was now or never and
arrested almost 20 members of the firm
hoping that the evidence they had
gathered would be enough to convince
some of them to take deals
fortunately the craze did a lot of the
hard work for them because their master
plan to avoid jail time
any murders was simply to have other
members of the firm take the blame on
their behalf
shockingly this wasn't well received and
some of those gang members gave evidence
against the craze
of particular importance was the
testimony of a former business partner
of the firm
named leslie payne he was the one that
jack the hat failed to kill so
naturally since the craze had put a hit
out on him he didn't feel particularly
loyal towards them lastly the barmaid at
the blind beggar accepted police
protection and identified ronnie cray as
the man who killed george cornell in
1969 ronnie and reggie cray were each
found guilty of murder and sentenced to
life in prison with a minimum of 30
years served this was at the time the
longest sentence for murder given out at
the old bailly eight other gangsters
were found guilty of murder or being
accessories to murder
bringing an end to the firm for a few
years the brothers were together in the
maximum security wing of parkhurst
prison
however with ronnie schizophrenia
getting worse he was transferred to
broadmoor mental hospital where
he spent the rest of his life until his
death in 1995 at the age of 61.
reggie cray was released from prison on
compassionate grounds in september 2000
due to terminal cancer
and he spent the last few weeks at home
before dying the following month age 66.
the crazed grasp on the criminal london
underworld might have ended over 50
years ago
but the notoriety and unique place in
pop culture
is still going strong so i really hope
you enjoyed today's video if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below don't forget to subscribe once
again thanks to magic spoon for
sponsoring
there's a link to them below and thank
you for watching
[Music]
you